you've seen the latest conspiracy no
nukes aren't real what yeah that one's
been that one's been cooking on Twitter
really nukes aren't real wow yeah what's
the what's the uh like reasoning oh dude
just to like keep us controlled so
there's like no we have nukes it was
just more like uh
they're not real
the if they're so powerful then
why how do we have footage of it
this footage that we've always
referenced it's clearly fake damn dude
people eat that [__] up now yeah crazy
you know fun like [__] that's why I
wanted to talk about the woman on the
plane because like the video is whatever
it's like kind of funny yeah you know
it's like literally like
not even close to the craziest thing
I've seen on a plane like the video did
you see the video
oh yeah the lady that's like that guy's
not real
and then she like walks away which yeah
it's like it's like not it's like not
even in the top five craziest people or
things I've seen on a plane like planes
are just like stupid environments like
crazy [__] happens all the time you know
yeah
I wish I remember her name I saw
stand-up comic say that uh this is like
actually I think one of the funniest
bits I've heard in a while
she's saying that once they made the
once Spirit made the flight so cheap
it's like she's like you're not on an
airline that [__] is just public transit
yeah yeah exactly yeah it's just like a
city bus yeah exactly so yeah sorry I'm
just saying that lends to your yeah
yeah exactly it's like you know you look
at that video and you're like okay she
clearly something like you know she
didn't get enough sleep she was a little
bit drunk yeah or something like that
yeah but we see that [__] all the time
on planes yeah and all the top comments
are like
she knows something she she definitely
saw something like uh why haven't we
heard it from her yet right like why why
did they take her what was what did she
see it's like what did you what
do you think she really saw like a
lizard person and there's like it's the
top comments so everyone's upvoting them
did you read what she claimed she saw
what no
she saw a man in a green hoodie blink
vertically
vertically it's just crazy that like the
default now is to be like well there's
lizard people she definitely saw a
lizard person because I was a real yeah
isn't it
yeah the idea is reptilian
Body Snatchers are inside politicians
and stuff yeah yeah that's the guy in
the hoodie hi holy [__] if you were like
an all-knowing like one of the like you
know Body Snatchers why would you be
sitting coach yeah
right just trying to blend in don't you
have like don't you run the Illuminati
and [__] like that it's true
yeah flying coach as part of the
Illuminati would be a No-No for me yeah
if I'm in the Illuminati I better get
PJs everywhere yeah
I better get private 747s every you
would yeah definitely
um this guy says he was on the flight
what does our boy have to say
before she really started getting
frantic like was paying attention that
makes sense it was like a normal flight
this was after putting all the luggage
away we'd been on the plane for a little
bit it was before the flight attendant
came over and gave the little Spiel and
what I remember
is
she was having like a full-blown
conversation with this dude in the
hoodie I'll call him the hoodie guy she
was having a full-blown conversation
with hoodie guy the weird thing was that
he never once said a [__] word to her
the whole time and at the time I I don't
know I wasn't really thinking about it
but it was like she it's like she would
say something and he like would respond
he would respond but what I mean that's
isn't that isn't that just more proof
that she's a [__] weirdo
why are you having a one-sided
conversation with somebody the weird
thing was after she
the plane the dude in the hoodie looked
back at me
and he winked at me but now that I look
back I realize that when he winked at me
and it was his left eye looking back at
me it didn't wink like this it winked oh
oh okay
so he wasn't on he wasn't on the flight
right that's just totally fake 100 you
think so yes a hundred percent next time
some [__] like this happens we have to
do this yeah well I'm like go on and be
like I was on that flight yeah
I was one of the people that was on that
flight and you won't believe what
happened well I think what's really
funny Idris Elba was jacking off in the
back seat vertically
he was jacking off but he wasn't jacking
off normally
he was jacking off horizontally
I don't want to misquote what happened I
thought that she claimed someone blanked
vertically
so now I'm confused as if as if he is
pretending to make the claim it doesn't
matter it's none of it's real yeah well
that guy isn't real
yeah
because that's what I'm saying yeah we
don't know what to believe yeah
so I'm just laughing at a drunk woman
freaking out and then a dude with noise
canceling headphones just like
exactly and she's like so what do you do
for work he's like
so why why are you answering me
what's wrong what's going on
what's going on with this guy
I'm in a hypnosis he's hypnosis
hypnotizing me
he's not real
yeah exactly
some dude writing python
python
this guy's a freak he's a lizard
and he was writing code in Python
and there's a reason why I'm getting the
either Believe it or they cannot believe
it I don't give two
but I am telling you right now that
[__]
that [__] back there is not real
and you can sit on this plane and you
can dive in fear or not I'm not going to
she's hammered dude I I hate all the
comments that are like you can hear the
fear in her voice cause she's [__]
hammered yeah you know there's one
person who's like
so does that mean her overhead bins open
yeah yeah yeah
I would love to put my backpack up yeah
yeah
I think the lizard guy is kind of cute
so is the seat beside him yeah open now
is that an exit row [__] yeah whatever
heard you're a snake yeah yeah what's up
all right all right whatever
yeah I guess he isn't real I guess you
won't mind this then just puts his
backpack in his seat boom nice if there
was a seat open beside that guy yeah
and he was a lizard I'd be like whatever
yeah you know as long as I'm not [__]
in the middle up here taking the aisle
for sure yeah exit row yeah what's up
with the snake you know how are you how
are you
this guy likes ice cream yeah yeah this
guy likes ice cream he ain't chewing he
ain't chewing his food don't bring this
guy a chicken can we get can we get this
guy a [__] live mouse or something I
want to see you go down
someone thank you oh my god
oh damn
yo
yo that's just you see that [__] [__]
holy [__] you can you can believe that
or you can choose not to believe that
but I don't know what that chick was
talking about he's definitely real real
[__] weird real weird you are an
animal my man literally love you you're
a [__] freak oh my God and you're
like I bet you like this and you just
angle your reading light to him yeah and
he's like yeah
oh [__] let's put some heat on that skin
you are scaly my man
lotion or some [__] ew foreign
foreign